st. Louis has also been involved for
quite some time she's currently deputy
director of the Jubilee USA Network
which is an alliance of more than 75
groups working for the definitive
cancellation of crushing debt to fight
poverty her article in reflections was
about Haiti and our responsibility to
not just postpone the payment but really
to forgive the debt of countries like
Haiti that have such crushing burdens
that it is really immoral I think and
unjust was your argument not to address
that in a more humane way you would
executive director of witness for peace
and you work for campaign for labor
rights we're not going to get into labor
rights tonight that isn't our subject
but you were at the Solidarity center of
the afl-cio and when we spoke a moment
ago what really struck me Melinda is
that you want to talk about what's
happening right now on the hill and that
is if anything a great challenge where
we do have to be very brave and
forthright if not aggressive so go ahead
Melinda what can you tell us well again
I want to thank everyone for the ale
University and reflections for the
opportunity to be here and and Senator
Coons comments I was really deeply moved
by his reflections on his experience in
Kenya and in the United States and that
resonated really deeply with me because
while my experience is different it was
in the slums in some Salvador and enroll
Nicaragua and the stories after the
Haiti earthquake and then being here in
in Washington I do think it is a
struggle to to keep those human faces
present all the time in our advocacy
even as advocates working on these
issues and so that's I feel like a
challenge that I want to continue to
bring forward and I think Jubilee USA
Network and I'm actually feel like I'm
talking to all of my bosses there are
lots of members of the Jubilee USA
Network all of the churches that are
here today I'm
have been on the on the front lines of
this movement since the mid-90s the the
job of the Jubilee USA network is really
to try to provide the knowledge and
tools for people of faith to you know to
bring that human face to public
discourse and to make sure that we're
not forgetting that and and so is the
comments I would like to make is just
really that that there is the power of
the faith community to make change in
public policy and in complicated
economic policy that is about economic
injustice and about fighting poverty and
as many probably know the story of the
Jubilee movement is is that that there
were people that were willing to
challenge of the ekit the economic
paradigms and say you know you're being
you're telling us that loan contracts
between with these governments that
those are sacred but really what sacred
is human dignity and our sacred texts
tell us that it is time for us to to
engage in debt cancellation so that
these resources can be invested in
health care education and so forth in in
a way that the changes some of the power
dynamics and that we're not just talking
about a charity model and and at the
time we were told it couldn't be done
and it's a story of churches and people
in the pews and institutional leaders
standing up and saying no we can change
this public policy and actually have
made really important gains a hundred
billion dollars have in debt stock has
been cancelled 32 countries have
received debt cancellation and that has
translated into concrete investments on
the ground in many of these countries so
I think that that's a story that we need
to be bringing and it's an unfinished
agenda and actually the fact that the
senator spoke about Kenya Kenya actually
was left out of those deals so there are
countries that have been that that need
continued debt cancellation and then
countries that fall into crisis like in
Haiti where we need to do that but in
terms of
but I really think that it's reflecting
on Lent and on the idea of sacrifice in
Lent I think who we sacrifice for really
says a lot about what we consider to be
sacred and the fact that in our national
discourse right now that there is
discussion about disproportionately
cutting programs at home and abroad that
serve the least among us at a time when
we're not expecting the wealthiest
individuals to even pay the tax rate
that they paid under the Riggin reagan
administration or we're not willing to
even look at the massive military
expenses that I consider it to be a very
false choice and I think it really is
incumbent upon the faith community to
bring that message forward to say you
know I mean we can we need to say these
are tough times and they are tough times
but we are making prioritization choices
as a nation and as communities and we
and and you know the senator said this
is less than one percent of our budget
you hear people all the polls say people
think that we pay twenty-five thirty
percent of our national budget and
foreign assistance we we need to say
this is less than one percent this is
important for us to be moving forward
and I and so I think that the faith
community is also very important not
only because of our moral message but
also because we do successfully cross
party lines this is not a democratic
issue it's not a Republican issue we
have Democrats Republicans greens tea
partiers are in the pews and we are
talking about these issues from a moral
standpoint and that was the Jubilee
movement was able to do that on the debt
movement and we continue to move that
forward so I will end here but I do want
to just make a little plug that we have
a thousand faith leaders letter to
President Obama on some of these
economic justice issues that we are
pushing and so if you are a faith leader
we have a sign up outside that you can
look at it and and encourage you to sign
that and we'd like to present that to
both Congress and the administration
Thank You Melinda and thank you for your
emphasis on making the moral arguments
as you all have that it moral and the
practical arguments and these are
ambitious
goals but they are worthy I'm going to
quote something that our Dean Harry
Attridge said in this reflections and
then another person did as well quoting
Dorothy Day no one has the right to sit
down and feel hopeless there is too much
work to do